[музыка]
я там кричала Я там пела я там танцевал
путешествие Бразилия - это путешествие
про эмоции
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
вот мы приехали в сам Пауло Это самый
крупный город в южной Америке вот
представляете в самом городе живёт 125
млн человек а в месте с пригородами 21
млн человек проживает сан-пауло но
первое что конечно нас удивило это то
что аэропорт не такой большой и не
соотвествует масштабу города Ягу
аэропорта мы сейчас находимся на самом
крупном муниципальном рынке Сан Пауло
это такой по нашему если брать аналогию
это Зелёный базар где город закупает
свежа или фермерские продукты Ну первое
впечатление конечно очень чисто здесь и
очень гигиенически ВС правильно
оформлено ВС в упаковках ВС чистенько и
так далее рынок примечателен тем что
здесь очень много фресок
72 фрески и он Ну по крайней мере была
попытка оформить очень художественно
красивый Этот рынок
ноно так как я видел много разных рынков
я вам скажу что это один из лучших
которые я видел я обязательно пою
центральные для того чтобы
поня мен понять Вообще чем Они питаются
их национальную кухню вообще через рынок
можно узнать весь город это такой
маленький срез срез города Кто здесь
живёт Какие национальности Какую еду они
кушают и через рынок можно понять Вообще
культуру питания и вообще культуру людей
и вот прямо передо мной я покажу фреска
которая состоит из семидесяти двух
стёкол посмотрите какая красивая фреска
это одно из достопримечательностей
города сан-пауло
Сан паулос знаменит тем что во-первых
много беспорядочный некров здесь
интересная архитектура такая и такое
стиль эклектика очень много различных
зданий очень много различных стилей нету
какого-то единого стиля и это наверное
придаёт какой-то определённый Шарм этому
городу но ещё конечно Сан Пауло знаменит
своими пробками к счастью мы ещё ни разу
не попадали в пробки но представте 125
млн город и 25 мл вместе с окрестностями
в этом городе что творится я вам скажу
так улицы здесь не самые широкие
вы знаете среда са сама по себе имеет
огромную ценность просто неописуемо
огромную ценность потому
среде вы находитесь В какой среде вы
общаетесь напрямую влияет на качество
вашего мышления и на качество вашего
ощущения ценности вашей жизни
[аплодисменты]
objetivo nosso aqui SE nos E amares obt
de ua E fogo ади
И сейчас мы идём значит в самы жестокие
Джунгли Амазонии где Возможно столк со
смертельным риском потому что возможно
может поджидать нас будут племена
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
индейцев питаются они в основном
небольшими животными там ляшками
грызунами и поднимаются по деревьям
чтобы питаться яйцами птиц примерно по-2
ме она может
ориентация информация по поводу
выживания сельва для того чтобы выжить в
джунглях необходимо два очень важных
фактора это вода и питание питание может
быть разделено на животное ну питание
животных и растений
[музыка]
sem
eu мы пришли в спа современно
Сегодня мы пришли добывать воду вот
команду всю накормил теперь они хотят
пить им надо кофе капучино а для этого
нужна вода а так как мы организаторы
ничего не остаётся делать Как добывать
им Теперь воду и вот мы нашли Лиану
которая которая полая внутри и содержит
воду внутри но Вся фишка в том что надо
разрубить её двумя ударами очень быстро
иначе вода поднимется вверх и уйдёт
Поэтому в моих руках в руках этого маче
практически судьба половины этого лагеря
Если сейчас не добудем воду просто
половину придётся как-то избавиться от
половины Либо мы добываем воду Либо мы
пол группы куда-нибудь
[музыка]
Дева давайте без стакана без стакана
Давайте
Вы только что видели как я спас половину
команды добы воду А теперь давайте
посмотрим на механику смотрите Лиана Как
устроена Лиана Она очень пористая она не
сказать что полностью полая но она
пористая и фокус в том что когда вы
отрубается в том промежутке который
отрубили А вода если вы не рубите с
одного раза уходит сразу вверх сразу
вверх Это интересный эфект Воже здесь за
счёт процесса осмоса
осмислити день команда пока вся живая
Надеюсь доедем до благополучно доедем до
дома постучать это самое известное
дерево в амазоне оно крона этого дерева
может достигать 4 мтро Джунгли нас
конечно поразили своим гостеприимством
во-первых когда идёшь в тишине по
джунглям слышишь Все истинные звуки
природы как они с тобой
разговаривают эи
они значит чем-то делятся здесь очень
сложно чем-то делиться это хорошая
практика
хорошая компания людей которые дают
Позитив те же эмоции которые я не могу
описать так как их настолько много и они
приобретаются в каждую минуту Даже
несмотря на какой-то отдых сессии походы
И вообще это такой образ жизни который
мне нравится Поэтому я здесь
[музыка]
а к сожалению периодически
M
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
мы находимся в поселении племени сила
что переводится с индийского наречия
переводится как Счастливые люди это
племя которое находится не так далеко от
города Манаус но относительно недалеко
наве
20 что на самом деле для амазонских
джунглей очень-очень много и вот мы
сейчас посетили туристический комплекс
который они специально сделали для
приёма туристов но мы их попросили
всё-таки показать их настоящую жизнь и
там где они реально живут вообще это
племя Оно интересно тем что уже Много
веков сохраняет свои традиции свою
культуру танцы и вот они сегодня
показывали нам свои приветственные танцы
как они общаются
ка у х есть ритуалы и
да это та культура в которой мы живём мы
её поддерживаем то есть с наших первых
миров с нашего первого рождения а мы
культивируем и продолжаем эту традицию
ритуалы и это всё живое для нас
Отлично
[аплодисменты]
вот нет вкусно реально как реш
[музыка]
пожа активировал
сегодня Сегодня мы здесь ужинаем в лесах
Амазонии в джунглях Они контактируют
активно контактируют с тремя четырьмя
другими племенами мы задавали вопросы а
как вы вообще общаетесь Как вы женитесь
оказывается они у них есть список плем
или не
список название племён дружественных с
которыми они могут жениться Ну и
свататься есть племена с которыми они ни
в коем случае не общаются в целом
конечно интересное место удалённое от
цивилизации вообще в Амазонии нету дорог
на амазонке есть только сообщения по
реке основные все сообщения между
городами это либо воздушным транспортом
либо по реке причём воздушный транспорт
ясно что не во всём посёлке не в каждом
и до сих
пор вообще в лесах Амазонии проживает
очень много племён которые даже ни разу
не не контактировали с цивилизацией
культура местный этот
колорит интересно очень конечно немного
влажно как видно вот но интересно самое
главное Комаров я не знаю может быть их
ГТО както
бо
этон кода нет коров кода вот это вот не
танцуе
[музыка]
N vem
второй поток
[музыка]
это делается что дельи оглохли и
всплыли
чтото
красный ом
больши мечтала поплавать с дельфинами и
сегодня моя мечта осуществилась мне
переполняют эмоции так что всё классно
[музыка]
казах сейчас видим слияние двух рек
первый раз такое вижу вообще вода не
перемешивается поэтому рекомендую всем
посетить Бразилию интересная страна
[музыка]
Oh Oh
Мы приехали на место рыбалки это как у
нас в алмаке есть место где рыбачат на
форель но там если мы рыбачим на крючок
то здесь рыбачит просто на рыб и это
такая Огромная рыба наверное килограммов
30-40 вытащить их невозможно
[музыка]
gir gir gir gira gira
gira aqui no
agu gira gira gir gira gira gir no
atabaque no
ugu entra na roda O barac chu PR bater
palme para tocar
tambu entra na roda O marac CH
B Pal
cata gira gira gir gira gira
gir gira gira gir gira gira gir atabaque
do
aru entra na roda O marac me chamou
[музыка]
на у нас сегодня очень насыщенный план
мы стартуем сечас 7:30 сейчас едем потом
на вертолёт площадку будем делать облёт
реде Женей и статуи Христа это одно из
рукотворных чудес света после облёта
статуи Христа ирее де Жанейро мы
спускаемся и у нас есть экскурсии по
городу осмотр доже Нера здесь
при
Маши Сзади меня находится вертолёт
а350 B3 это вертол
ком это мой первый вертол который я себе
купил его особенность в том что он
предназначен для Жарких климатов и
горных
мест сечас тут Атмосфера и Аура почему
тут все предприниматели тут все
бизнесмены тут все миллионеры
миллиардеры Ну сейчас уже будет о
летал на вертолётах в основном это
всё-таки северные направления были у нас
в России Байкал Алтай Карелия Но вот так
чтобы в Южной Америке и над океаном это
впервые Поэтому с нетерпением жду нашего
полёт и надеюсь что все ожидания
оправдаются
[музыка]
H
рядом с маргуланом ковим я держалась
молодцом но Я не знаю если я была бы
одна в
верте я бы там наверно во весь голос
кричала бы и плакала бы от счастья и
Честно говоря я не смогла все эти эмоции
вытащить но знаете Это самый лучший
момент в моей жизни всё это дело блин не
забываем с вертолёта летать и смотреть
на людей сверху когда они там статуя
большая и там много людей А ты с вертол
них Смотри это вае оние
по бешеные островки на в океане поля
дома на каждом доме есть футбольные поля
почти теннисные карты виды обалденные
просто супер понравилось
супер супер просто
впечатление особенно вокруг статуи
Христа мы летели это вообще невероятное
чтото прямо эмоции зашкаливает тут
классно Там вы видели да как высоко мы
поднимались вообще
[музыка]
класс Бразилия
ри Вот это место известное во всё
осталось буквально несколько ступенек и
мы там
[музыка]
место
потрясающее благодаря вот этому туру
маргулана оказаться в этом месте о
котором я в детстве мечтал много раз
слышал видел по телевизору но когда ты
находишься здесь самостоятельно
чувствуешь Вот это всё глазами руками мы
сейчас находимся на самой лучшей
обзорной точки города Рио де Жанейро
сзади меня расстилается Старый город же
мечта всех путешественников наверно
мечта всех людей начиная от оста Бендера
заканчивая любым человеком который более
мене
разбирается Слушай ну на маргула
подписан давно а сегодня у меня Задача В
этом году сделать так чтобы я выехал
один раз с интересными по духу по мыслям
людьми в Новую страну и вс совпало
интересные лютой
страна в которой я ещ не был поэтому
невероятные впечатления знаешь как три в
одном Что может быть
[музыка]
лучше потом будем на п
par
[музыка]
мы сейчас
приехали посмотреть фавелы вокруг Рио де
Жанейро вообще Рио де Жанейро город
контрастов здесь в фалах это пому
переводится как
трубы 35 мл человек и особенность л в
том что люди здесь не платят ни налогов
ни коммунальных платежей ничего и
проживание в Лах обходится им дёшево А
так как средняя зарплата и минимальная
зарплата в Бразилии около 220 долларов
То их понять можно И эти люди живут в
этих фавелах здесь власть не работает
там работают коммунны глава какой-то Шеф
может быть даже преступные организации
короче нас предупреждали что здесь может
быть интересно мы спокойно шли Ну мы не
обращали внимания Ну думаю наверное там
э чересчур надута это мы берём телефоны
все идём снимаем и тут выходит там
местная банда и что-то с криками там с
лицами очень агрессивными начинают там
забирать у каждого по одному Ну телефону
и там открывай быстрее там удаляй
картинки там и так далее И после этого
Конечно мы все немножко так оп здесь
надо быть осторожнее короче уже больше
телефоны не вытаскивали удивительно было
увидеть настолько открытый мир люди
ходят с УЗИ пистолетами снайперскими
винтовками рядом с тобой там ходят
наркотиками с оружие телефоны забирали
Наши в целом контраст был очень сильный
друзья мы находимся в фавелах Рио де
Жанейро в одном из Больших самых главных
фал здесь Проживает около 250 людей и мы
знаем что в нашем представлении фавел -
это преступность это наркотики это
оружие и мы сейчас пройдя По главной
улице в этом убедились У нас отнимали
телефоны стирали наши записи и так далее
и по улицам реально ходят люди с
пистолетами с наркотиками и не
скрываются и из-за того что у нас было
несколько стычек с бандитами не то что
стычек мы-то с ними не комплектовать Но
они отнимали у нас телефоны они
позвонили Я так понимаю главе этой
общины И сегодня я вот мы хотим
поговорить с главой этой общины бошко он
президент этой общины Я хочу ему Задать
несколько вопросов Я думаю вам тоже
будет очень любопытно мы попросили у
него разрешение на съёмку И вот он
согласился любезно нам ответить на наши
вопросы Ну наверное это везде в мире так
происходит наверняка в каких-то моментах
и в вашей
мы не пересекаемся но мы дружественно
мирно
сожительство вы тут со своими делами А
мы тут вы нам не мешаете и мы вам не
мешаем независимая мы находимся вот
здесь в фале и мы зависим только от
фавелы То есть это не государстве А кто
финансирует тогда а на самом деле жители
взно делают взносы небольшие допустим
человек живёт здесь документ на дом у
него нет но у него сч приходит он идт
показывает счёт вот я житель
зарегистрируйте меня здесь платит 10
реалов то есть они вот таким
образом Кто отвечает за туристов в
принципе наша администрация вот
буквально в прошлом месяце сюда приезжал
один из самых крупных волшебников Да кто
фокусы фокусников показывает Дэвид
н связывался с общиной проводил см
наверху поднимался
большая естественно в принципе никаких
проблем за исключением вот что-то
засняли не то произошло
недопонимания языковой барьеры Ну и
допустим там драка где-то случилась
поэтому поэтому в принципе мы должны
знать когда идёт большая группа потому
что это наша ответственность И мы
охватить всю холу не можем
[музыка]
е просто супер впечатление
летаешь прямо как Париж вообще суп
[музыка]
нереа 2
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
ещё одно Моё первое на вертолёте первый
раз теперь на дельтаплане первый раз в
жизни вообще супер впечатление Я офигел
столько эндорфинов выделяется страшно
Молодцы инструкторы профессионалы в
принципе успокаивают На них смотришь
типа не страшно никакой жути не нагоняет
просто берёшь там обрыв 10 м надо
пробежать рядом с ним не смотреть вниз и
при этом не останавливаться и в пропасть
прыгать короче впечатление на горячую на
горячую я там кричала Я там пела я
танцева сча я чу-чуть
поплакала зашкаливает Это нечто
даже пипец Мне было страшно у меня вес А
я Это бомба Мой инструктор просто Гуру
37 лет опыта Вообще полное спокойствие
доверие
е руки Я вообще хочу сказать что
путешествие Бразилия - это путешествие
про
[музыка]
эмоции мы на вершине самой высокой точки
Рио дене эта гора называется сахарная
голова в своё время её прозвали потому
что эта гора была голая это
вулканического происхождения она чёрная
и наверху очень много
гнездилов помёта вершина головы была
белой А и поэтому А так как Бразилия
экспортировала очень много сахара
тростника то местные жители и
португальцы
назвали эту гору сахарная голова потому
что это голо гора похожа на один большой
кусок сахара мы побывали в
фавелах в риод же Нера Это было очень На
мой взгляд опасное путешествие мы только
туда зашли и сразу получили угрозу жизни
мне кажется там увидели и оружие и таких
бравых ребят которые Ну были определённо
настроены агрессивно Ну благодаря нашим
э помощникам
получилось хорошо и
мы чудом выжившие оттуда Выбрались
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
V
р
uh
[музыка]
зачем я ускорил мо
о у
[музыка]
Почему
умирает вообще откуда у нас появляется
неуверенность заметьте слово
неуверенность происходит от слова нету
Веры нету веры а вообще Вера Откуда
происходит А давайте вот поймём саму
природу сначала
а у нас есть информация потом на основе
информации мы
э информация э она превращается в знание
вот что такое знание и информация
информация - Это всё что нас окружает а
знание - это информация
структурированная определённым образом А
теперь самих знаний недостаточно чтобы
была уверенность и менять свою жизнь для
этого нужно Понимание Вот что такое
понимание понимание - это когда мы
разбираемся в том как это устроено и
причина следственная связ то есть
по-простому ответ на два вопроса как это
устроено и как это работает и вот когда
вы понимаете как это работает и как это
устроено вы знаете на эту кнопку нажму
произойдёт Вот это на эту кнопку нажму
произойдёт Вот это дёрнуть за этот рычаг
произойдёт это вот выключатель Когда вы
включаете выключается свет У вас же нету
неуверенности потому что вы чётко знаете
сейчас нажму свет погаснет нажму свет
включится так ведь А и таким образом
уверенность у вас появляется когда у вас
есть чёткое понимание причины
следственной связи а соответственно А
что получается как вот эта уверенность
причино следственной связи даёт нам
Веру нам Веру что если мы нажмём будет
Вот это вот эта связь между вашим
действием и результатом Вот даёт веру а
Вера Что приводит Вера даёт нам
уверенность и Благодаря этой уверенности
мы начинаем действовать
[музыка]
Я был очень рад провести все эти там 7-8
дней вместе с вами это ведь наш кусочек
нашей жизни Вот такой знаете маленький
сегмент жизни который мы вырвали и
посвятили друг
эти дни будут
незабываемые они тем более эмоционально
насыщенные были Непростые дни мы вместе
переживали яркие события и я уверен
каждый из вас вы запомните друг друга
завтра мы уже разлета ися в разные
страны мира но не хочу говорить Прощайте
хочу всем сказать до свидания до новых
встреч потому что здесь и так есть много
ребят которые со мной уже куда-то ездили
с которыми я уже пытался прощаться но
они вот семьями даже продолжают здесь
обитать Вот они вон много здесь таких но
поэтому я хочу сказать до свидания Не
Прощаемся надолго до свидания впереди
нас ждёт ещё яркая жизнь жизнь полная
приключений мы эти дни провели не просто
так а с глубоким смыслом И не только
смысл который мы получали от природы но
и друг от друга Ну и надеюсь я тоже на
это оказал какое-то влияние поэтому
спасибо всем До новых встреч
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]